Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness.
Today, we're talking about holiness and the mind.
You have an incredible gift between your ears.
It's about two or three pounds of gray matter called your
brain. And your brain, God calls it
to participate in the grand project of
holy and being holy like He was.
Jesus also had a brain,
and his brain was particularly our
example of holiness. So if you want to know, is it possible to
be holy and have a normal human brain? Yes, it is.
Look at Jesus. However, there are certain things that we have to do.
In 1 Corinthians, and I'll give you some verses right here, 1
Corinthians 2:16,
there is a really significant verse that says, "We have
the mind of Christ." Now, that doesn't mean you have Jesus'
physical brain, doesn't mean that you know everything He knows.
What it means is that your mind is oriented toward
God in the same way that Jesus' is, that you
have set your mind to love God as Christ does.
By the way, the mind is incredibly
powerful but can be corrupted by the will.
So when the will is surrendered to God and the
nature of sin, the corruption of that influence is
cleansed from the heart and from the will,
then the mind is set free to become what it ought to
be, but it does take some work and some layering on.
Because all the education in the world, if it's corrupted by self and
sin, will not make you orient toward God.
But if you're willing to orient, and Philippians 2:5 tells us
even more about this. It says, "Let this mindset be in you."
Mind, mindset be in you, which is also in Christ
Jesus.
And then it talks about his humility and surrender to
God. And he talks about that in the context
of relationships. So the mind becomes very important in the
context of relationships. The way you think about and what you
expect from others and what you think you deserve from others is an
incredibly powerful thing that sets you up for success or failure in
your relationships and your holiness in your life.
Your mindset is powerful. You've got to orient yourself
humbly toward God and others, just like Jesus did in his
mind. The next thing is Hebrews 8:10,
which is a beautiful verse that talks
about how God is going to put his
laws in our minds. And so we have to
orient ourselves toward the word of God like Jesus
did. When Jesus was tempted, he used his mind and
the
things that he had stored up there in his mind, the scriptures he had stored up
there, and they came back to him, and he was able to do battle with the enemy
and win the battle against temptation. Why? Because his mind was there.
His mind was oriented toward the word of God.
So you have to orient your mind toward God.
Now, I wrote these down in the wrong order, but I numbered them in the correct
order. This is in 2 Corinthians
10:5, really interesting verse. Sometimes we may find
that a thought comes into our mind from our
habits of thought, or from tiredness, or brain fog, or sickness, or
the culture, or our family
way of thinking. A thought comes into our mind that we
recognize as not compatible with holiness.
And in that moment, we have to capture.
So we have orientation of a general orientation toward God, and toward his
word, and toward humility, but then we have to capture things that don't fit that
pattern.
So this verse says, "Take every thought into
captivity to the obedience of Christ." Now, that might be in other
people's minds sometimes if you're discussing with someone and you want to capture
their thoughts and make them obey Christ,
but it definitely applies to your mind as well,
doesn't it? You have that thought of pride or
lust or tiredness or anger or a wicked
response or
complaining or
pride and self-righteousness towards somebody else.
You've had those thoughts. When you see them go by,
don't conclude that it must mean that
there's nothing left and my mind is just, "Oh, no, this is so terrible.
My mind, I must not be actually right with God. I must not be saved.
I must not be filled with the Holy Spirit." No. Capture that thought.
It's on its way by. The devil himself can put thoughts into your
mind. As he goes by, capture it, recognize it,
capture it, and make it obey Jesus.
And if you frequently happen to notice
a pattern of thoughts that frequently plagues you and you have
frequently captured those thoughts and make them obey Jesus,
then you need to do something a little differently.
You need to renew your mind.
Romans 12:2 says, "Be transformed by the
renewing of your mind." Let's see if I can explain.
Your mind literally has the ability to
rewire itself. If you take
out a portion of your brain that deals with speech
during a surgery or something like that, your brain literally can
rewire itself to develop that speech
over again.
It's incredible thing. In fact, it's called neuroplasticity, and there's
a whole
bunch of science and studies done on it in recent decades.
In fact,
the part of the brain that does math grows and grows
stronger if you do math frequently.
Literally, every time a thought jumps, an electrical impulse jumps across a
synapse in your brain, it becomes stronger until finally you've got a
superhighway in your brain. Now, if you have old superhighways in your
brain that are lustful, evil, wicked sets of thoughts,
you're going to have to capture those frequently at the beginning.
But you're going to use that to renew your mind, and you're going to literally
build new superhighways in your brain. You can do that.
It's incredible. God has made it so you can rewire and
reprogram your brain,
and you can do this by capturing and telling yourself the
truth that God says about that issue.
Let me just give you an example from the Old Testament.
David said to himself, instead of listening to his mind, he spoke to
his mind. He said, "Why are you disquiet?
Why are you downcast, O my soul? And why are you disquieted within me?
Hope in God."
Right?
What was he doing? Instead of just listening to his brain and being the
victim of his thoughts and being led around by the nose by his thoughts,
instead of that, he chose a different pathway, and he
chose to capture that thought and then speak to it
and order it to do what it was supposed to do.
If you'll do that, what you'll find is that your brain will, over the course
of time, this is not instantaneous.
We're talking about time, maybe months, maybe years of
actually working on something.
You'll capture
thoughts that aren't obeying Christ.
You'll recognize them, you'll speak to them, and you will literally
reprogram and renew your mind. And then the last part of Romans
12:2 says that then it's easier to discern or
know the good, perfect, and acceptable, and
pleasing will of God. You want to know the will of
God. You want your mind to be open to those kinds of things.
You need to let your mind grow in holiness.
Your mind God calls to participate in the grand
project of your holiness. God bless you.
We'll see you tomorrow.